[Musica]
è pesante venite con me e vi farò
pastori di ai
Difficile da dire intanto mi presento
anche se non vi vedo perché ho la luce
puntata negli occhi mi chiamo Matteo
Flora insegno a una serie di aziende in
realtà aiuto le aziende a risolvere le
crisi e alcune volte ad anticiparle
usando la tecnologia e i dati perché
pastore via i per iniziare questo
viaggio abbiamo bisogno di partire da un
gatto colorato
In che senso un gatto colorato già
qualcuno di voi ha già giocato con una
delle ultime intelligenze artificiali
certe GPT seagp ti chiediamo
Come fare a vendere il mio nuovo
servizio di colorazione gatti
gibellino mi dice Matteo Smettila di
bere sei ubriaco gbt mi propone delle
argomentazioni mi dice che la
colorazione rende il gatto più visibile
e più e quindi più sicuro se soprattutto
se viviamo all'aperto una colorazione
Può essere usata per identificare il
gatto in caso di smarrimento addirittura
ribadire che la colorazione può creare
un look unico per il proprio gatto
rendendolo ancora più speciale e più
amato
questa cosa non gli è stata direttamente
insegnata questa cosa ha un nome che non
vogliamo dire ultimamente perché questa
cosa si chiama creatività ora il dire
che questa cosa è creatività ci fa paura
perché abbiamo sempre pensato alla
creatività come una qualità
distintiva proprio dell'intelligenza
umana addirittura gli accademici la
definiscono come l'abilità di generare
prodotti che sono nuovi originali utili
ed efficaci ed era una cosa nostra
solo degli esseri umani e se non rimane
più una cosa nostra è un problema Uno è
un problema perché assistiamo secondo
una buona parte degli Studi alla prima
rivoluzione industriale che non toccherà
la classe operaia come quelle che
abbiamo visto sinora Ma toccherà i
colletti Bianchi toccherà funzionari
incaricati
bancari ingegneri medici legali e non
siamo pronti non siamo pronti a gestire
un'intelligenza artificiale così brava
da capire addirittura le varie parti che
sottendono la realtà non banali Ad
esempio se chiedessi a qualcuno di qui
in sala meno di vent'anni che tipo di
relazione c'è tra una penna Bic e una
musica setta non me lo saprebbero dire
quelli che stanno ridendo sono dei
boomer benvenuti nel mio mondo
vi capisco benissimo per i non boomer
per risparmiare la batteria si metteva
la Bic nella musicassetta la si faceva
girare per riavvolgerla da una parte o
dall'altra se lo Chiedete a GPT ve lo
racconta perché perché
siamo in occasione di una delle poche
volte nella storia dell'umanità in cui
assistiamo a un'intelligenza artificiale
la prima da quella che abbiamo visto che
è in grado direbbe Mitchell di capire il
mondo
siamo in grado è in grado di passare
l'esame da avvocato il Triple bar
americano una serie di esami da
cardiologo da medico generico è in grado
di passare esami di matematica di fisica
di chimica a pieni voti come fosse un
essere umano e lì è ovvio che la prima
cosa che uno dice è
o diamine Non era esattamente odiamine
quello che stavo dicendo Ma mi hanno
detto di non dire parolacce che ne ha
dette troppe prima gli altri
porca di quella miseria Mi avete rubato
le mie parolacce
ci uccideranno tutti le intelligenze
artificiali possibili non mi sento di
escluderlo Ok C'è sempre quella grande
parte Se volete leggetevi super
intelligenza di vostron meraviglioso gli
scenari più impossibili Ma vi posso dire
che se non ci uccideranno Beh siamo però
di fronte a un cambiamento epocale nella
storia dell'umanità in cui una serie di
lavori non esisteranno più in realtà la
prima cosa di cui vi accorgerete è che
saremo tutti noi questa stanza la prima
generazione a subire la scelta delle
macchine
il mutuo che vi viene o non vi viene
assegnato la multa che vi viene non vi
viene assegnata la possibilità o meno di
entrare in quella posizione all'interno
del Pronto Soccorso la possibilità o
meno di attivare entrare in quella
scuola saranno decise principalmente
delle macchine il vostro curriculum
vitae selezionato da delle macchine e
questo apre una serie di
problematiche come le controlliamo Di
chi è la responsabilità hanno dei
pregiudizi o no Certo che hanno dei
pregiudizi sono addestrati su quello che
gli dicono gli esseri umani gli esseri
umani hanno pregiudizi le hanno anche le
macchine Eppure pensiamo di no e uno
dice vabbè in tutto questa parte non c'è
problema basta insegnare un po' di etica
etica la branca della filosofia che si
occupa di attribuire la definizione dice
un valore deontologico ai comportamenti
umani cioè dire che cos'è giusto o
sbagliato
come fosse facile dire giusto e
sbagliato e non è la morale è la morale
cambia a seconda dei dei posti a seconda
del tempo per chiunque dice vabbè ma è
facile capire cosa deve fare
un'intelligenza artificiale a queste
persone portano normalmente un pezzo di
un esperimento molto bello della myt il
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
che si chiama la Mortal machine una
serie di domande fatte a una serie di
esseri umani Su che cosa dovrebbe fare
una macchina in questo caso una macchina
che non può scherzare e può solo
prendere una decisione e uccidere un
bambino o un anziano e voi dite cosa c'è
da scegliere ovviamente tiro sotto
l'anziano eh in Occidente in Occidente
normalmente tiriamo sotto l'anziano
perché perché il bambino mille
potenzialità mille cose possibili
in Oriente tirano sotto il bambino senza
pensarci tutta la conoscenza
dell'anziano
come la recuperiamo
il valore per l'umanità di quella
conoscenza è incredibilmente superiore a
un bambino e ne facciamo un altro No
così non è venuta bene però
la prossima volta la faccio diversa
non riusciamo nemmeno a definire noi
come esseri umani che cosa fare e
dobbiamo
insegnarlo alle macchine macchine che
stanno diventando sempre di più e
continueranno a diventare sempre di più
nostri consiglieri come dei
professionisti chiediamo consulti medici
legali ingegneristici come Addirittura
in alcuni esperimenti terapeuti
ci sono una serie di terapie cognitivo
comportamentali che vengono portate
avanti ad esempio per il disturbo post
traumatico usando delle macchine sempre
più spesso facciamo domande a queste
intelligenze artificiali che ha sono
molto più vicine non tanto quello che
chiederemo a un professionista ma chi
chiederemo a degli oracoli Ecco se mano
a mano i nostri lavori si stima che
almeno tra il 40 e il 60 dei Cento dei
lavori saranno impattati in maniera
importante dall'intelligenza artificiale
Beh se dobbiamo
riuscire a fare questa coesistenza il
nostro ruolo come esseri umani quello
che mi chiedono i ragazzi adesso cosa
devo studiare Devi imparare a diventare
un pastore di intelligenza artificiale
Cosa significa significa che
l'intelligenza artificiale faranno
probabilmente buona parte dei lavori si
stanno già muovendo in quelle direzioni
tante aziende per implementarlo ma
avremmo bisogno di creare delle Policy
cioè di esseri esseri umani che
sorvegliano il gregge di ai e che
decidono i limiti avremo bisogno di
creare meccanismi di salvaguardia capire
cosa possono non possono fare in che
modi avremmo bisogno anche se
l'intelligenza artificiale faranno
creatività non so se l'avete notato
delle mie slide sono generate da
un'intelligenza artificiale non c'è una
foto reale
avremo bisogno di sovrintendenza
artistica qualcuno che capisca quali
delle cose create dov'era portare avanti
ce ne sono tanti di lavori che dovremmo
fare faremo i project manager come
adesso abbiamo sotto 100 ingegneri
avremo sotto 100 processi un certo tipo
ma il nostro lavoro cambierà in maniera
radicale e per farlo dobbiamo imparare a
comunicare non siamo nemmeno bravi a
comunicare con altri esseri umani
figuriamoci figuriamoci con quelle che
Boston Chiama nel problema delle
ortogonalità la prima intelligenza
aliena incontrata dall'umanità Aliena in
senso etimologico latino alienos altro
intelligenza non umana stiamo cercando
di relazionarci come faremmo con degli
umani con un intelligenza che umana non
è
e imparare a parlare è complesso
Dobbiamo capire come esprimere bene le
nostre intenzioni
Non solo ma Come definire esattamente le
nostre aspettative cosa ci aspettiamo
che la macchina faccia perché la
macchina non è un umano e non è in grado
di capire in autonomia non solo se
vogliamo imparare a coesistere è adesso
il momento nella vostra azienda di
pensare a quali processi saranno passati
a macchine e quali no
se siete Policy maker e adesso che
dobbiamo capire quali lavori saranno
assegnati o meno in che ambito
se avete qualunque tipo di ruolo
decisionale è adesso che vanno a
implementati i meccanismi di
salvaguardia tra umani e macchine è
adesso il momento in cui possiamo
scrivere le regole per coesistere perché
ricordatevilo bene quelle che state
vedendo adesso sono le quelle che hanno
Scusatemi quelle che hanno
fatto l'esame di avvocato passato
l'esame da medico passato l'esame da
ingegnere passato l'esame di chimico
passato l'esame di fisica quelli
intelligenza è la peggiore e più stupida
intelligenza artificiale che voi vedrete
in tutta la vostra vita da qui in poi al
contrario di tanti umani possono solo ed
esclusivamente migliorare e a ritmo
vertiginoso e questo significa
che continueremo a usare l'intelligenza
artificiale sempre più spesso per
chiedere
cosa è giusto cosa è sbagliato per
chiedere cosa accadrà nel futuro se una
persona commetterà di nuovo un delitto o
meno se quel titolo salirà o scenderà
Chiederemo di valutare cosa è giusto e
sbagliato per una persona cosa è giusto
o sbagliato Per me cosa giusta e
sbagliata per una popolazione un'azienda
l'intera umanità una figura questa che
conosciamo nella storia dell'umanità la
conosciamo molto bene
perché sono le stesse domande che nella
cultura umana abbiamo sempre sempre
rivolto a un Dio e la domanda con cui
volevo chiudere con voi perché non ho la
risposta ma mi piacerebbe lasciarla
aperta per discuterne con voi è
e Come si programma un Dio perché noi
ancora non lo sappiamo e siamo a tanto
tanto così di distanza Tutto qui
[Applauso]
un ultimo dettaglio tecnico tutte le
slide di questa presentazione tutto il
discorso di questa presentazione sono
state create Usando anche quelle
un'intelligenza artificiale così sapete
[Applauso]